foreign
[Music]
good morning and good afternoon to
everyone and welcome to today's webinar
reliable anti-fungal susceptibility
testing with Micronaut am according to
ucas standards
I'm Christy Jewel of laberts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by Lab Rats and sponsored by
bruker microbiology and Diagnostics
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit grouper.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical
questions here as well
now I would like to welcome today's
speaker Alex cost PhD f-a-m-h clinical
microbiologist University Hospital Luzon
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Alex you may now begin your presentation
so thank you for the nice introduction
my name is Alex cost and I'll present
you a RTD entitled a comparative
evaluation of micronutrium using
antifungal resistance genes to overcome
differences between ucast and clsi so
this study was performed in our
laboratory located at the University
Hospital Los Angeles called shiv which
is one of the five University Hospitals
in Switzerland yes Switzerland it's a
small country
um and these hospital is collaborating
with the faculty of biology and Medicine
of the University of Louisiana
that you can see here and our Institute
The Institute of microbiology is located
in this small house here and on the 19th
floor and 18th floor of the main
building
so in our Institute we have about 120
employees which are dedicated we who are
dedicated to three main activities so
the diagnostic uh in microbiology uh but
also applied and fundamental research
and teaching
so the diagnostic section uh of our
Institute is performing a wide range of
individual diagnostic tests in the field
of bacterology microbacteriology
parasitology serology biology and
mycology as you will see today and
molecular diagnostic also so the work I
present you today was performed by
Nicola Nicole apellato who was my master
student in 2020 and
some experiments were confirmed and
continued by a technician in our
Diagnostic lab not transition and this
was published as you can see here
so as all of you know
um we estimate the fungal kingdom are
about 1.5 million different species and
among them we estimated that around 300
species could provoke a disease in human
people
and indeed globally we can more or less
estimate that 300 million people are
afflicted with a serious fungal
infection and that 25 million are are at
a higher risk of dying of losing their
site so um this is more than the people
suffering cancer age TB or asthma
altogether and what is astonishing with
uh infectious infection due to fungus is
that they can go from very superficial
Disease by Benin to very severe one uh
essentially in immunocompromised
patients that are life-threatening and
we also recently also um
have a fungal infection associated with
covid-19 which could be really severe
um we uh evaluated that the mortality
due to uh invasive fungal infection
varies between 15 to 70 percent
depending on on the type of those
infections and there is an estimation of
1.5 million deaths per year due to
fungal infection
so it's not just a little problem
to fight against this infection
um
antifungal drugs were developed since
the mid uh 20th century with a
development of unfortunatarism be at
first then we had free Citizen and
asshole's class start to be released at
the beginning of 80s and a major
Improvement was done with ficonazole uh
in in beginning of 90s
and finally candines were released on
the market beginning of the 21st century
as you can see here in red
however at the same time uh as
antifungals were developed the
resistance arise and here on the right
you can see the level of
candida labrata antifungal resistance
um
which were isolated in bloodstream
infection
um and you you you see that a long time
uh this this candida glabrata acquire
resistance to the different drugs so
here you see the candidates and here the
uh on the bottom you can see the
candidates and above you can see the
hassles which there is much more
resistance to hazards and on the great
part you can see that there is some
strains which have which are multi-drug
resistant
um and this is particularly true also
not only for candida brabrata but also
for candida hours the New Kids on the
blocks of the candida which was isolated
for the first time into a line in Japan
and which is now present all over the
world and which really often present
multi-drug resistance for example to
adults and candines and also sometimes
to unfortunately simbae but this
resistance is not restricted to candida
Roberta or his but also to all
um the different fungi and here you have
a map you see
um which will
um
highlight the the rise of resistance
amongst here candida albicans
collaborate cryptococcus neoformance and
um especially these fumigators all
together
so
okay so you can see that you have seen
that this resistance arise all over the
world for all these four species and
it's not true only for those species but
for much much more
um so to to fight against resistance we
have to understand how the drug acts
first so
um
there is uh the the drug
um the three major sorry the three major
class of antifungals Acts on the uh the
cell membrane and the the the
[Music]
cell wall sorry so in the class in the
case of uh adults uh they will act on on
the cell membranes and integrity as they
will uh bind an enzyme called ERG 11
which is involved in the synthesis of
ergosterol which is the major sterol in
fungiate or fungi of ergosterol instead
of cholesterol and so if they block this
enzyme there is no more agosterol
synthetized in the fungal cells polyames
binds directly to ergoster halls and the
The Binding of amphotylicine beep which
is the main polyens use we lead to a
leaky membrane and the death uh of the
of the cells
the candidates as I said will act on the
cell wall and particularly the cell wall
uh biosynthesis they will bind in fact
to an enzyme called fks1 and in case of
candida grabarata there is two two genes
if case one and if Case two and once the
Canadian block this enzyme this will
impair the synthesis of beta13 grikan
which is the the main composite of the
the cell wall of fungus
um the resistance mechanisms to these uh
different antifungal are depicted here
on the right so
um there could be due the resistance
could be due to mutation in the target
of antifungal drugs such as early 11 or
FKS one or two which leads to a decrease
of binding Affinity with the drug
uh the second mechanism could be
um
a diminution of the of the target
content or a modification of the
metabolism of the fungus for example uh
if you have mutation in in enzymes that
are involved in the biosynthesis of
ergosterol there is no more ergosterol
for example and then for unfortunaticine
B could not bind anymore to ergosterone
the the third mechanism is the the
increase uh of the drug
Target expression uh due to mutation in
the transcription Factor regulating
um the expression of the genes encoding
this this drug Target here we have upc2
for example which regulate the
expression of l11 that which can be
mutated and finally uh the the
resistance could be due to an increased
expression of efflux pump
um
and these two will have a reduction of
intracellular accumulation of the drugs
and this is due to mutation in uh
transcription Factor here take one or
mr1 which control the expression of uh
this multi-drug pump
so um
so it is important uh to to
assess antifungal susceptibility as you
can see as resistance is is arising and
for that we need to to detect this uh
this resistance or a diminution of
deceptibility
and as you can see on the left of my
slide we don't have a rapid molecular
test to do so
um because there is uh too many genes
involving the resistance and in each
genes we have too many mutations so it's
not possible to have a single molecular
test to
um to detect antifungal resistance so we
are now limited we are still limited to
use a phenotypic
detection of antifungal resistance and
um
for that we follow two major protocols
so either the a cast or the clsi
protocol however these methods uh
especially as you can see uh on the
right the growth micro dilution
susceptibility testing it will be time
consuming and sometimes difficult to
read and so that's we urgently need uh
to have easy to under test in our
routine Laboratories
and uh
up to now we have uh on the market two
micro dilution commercial methods the as
you see on the left the yeast one
sensitive which is uh which follow the
the clsi protocol and which should be
interpreted with the CLS cyclitaria and
on the right there is a Micronaut am
which follow and the UPS protocol and
which should be interpreted with ucas
kitaya
so here I I put on that slide the
difference of uh of uh the protocols
here in red uh between clsi and ucast
and you see that there is major
difference in terms of inoculum but also
in terms of growth medium
and here another thing which makes a big
difference between the two protocols and
the two consoles yeah is the criteria of
interpretation so here it's a kind of a
summary of the different criteria
existing for both of them so you see in
this table uh either the the
epidemiological cutoff value or the
breakpoints and you see that for each
species there is uh on the left the clsi
criteria and on the right the ucas
criteria and you see that there is a lot
of blank cells in this Excel table and
it's because there is no criteria so you
see that
um
even if from clsi we have criteria you
we don't have them for youcast and vice
versa and for some we don't have any uh
at all neither for CLS sign or youcast
so in this study we we wanted to compare
these two micro dilution commercial
methods so the yeast one sensitizer
which was bred by I and interpreted with
the clsi criteria and the Micronaut am
read by I or with a spectrophotometer
and which was interpreted with ucas
criteria
by high when we read by high or
automatically with the software in our
spectrophotometer and computer
so to do so we used a collection of 97
strains uh covering 19 different yeast
species
essentially candida species including
candida albicans laborator luciteani and
Oris
cryptococcus species one psychomises
strain and one supported clavatta
and we analyzed the data for eight of
the nine anti-fungal drug tested as you
can see here in black and the Fly five
fusetazines in Gray was not analyzed in
in our study as it's a drug which is
quite normal used in clinic
okay so first we just compared uh
probably the mic we obtained with both
uh method uh read by I
so here it's a table summarizing that so
you can see that on the top we have the
overall comparison and then we detailed
this comparison by spaces so if we focus
on the overall comparison
we estimated that uh one dilution
difference between the two methods is
acceptable so it's why you see on the
right of this table that we have the
percent the global percent of equal or
one dilution apart comparison
and you see that overall around 67 of
the mic were comparable or identical
between the two methods meaning that
one-third of the mic were really
different between the two methods this
leads us to think and yeah in red here I
indicated the drug for which it's the
more uh the the difference is the more
severe let's say
connazole and Mika fungiene
so this leads us to to understand that
the mic could not be directly compared
at at the end they are not in
interpreted the same way so for that so
to to to to do the comparison we decided
to Define categories based on the mic
deletion respectively to breakfast or to
ikov ecv if they were available for both
Consortium let me explain you how we did
so if uh we had only a unique breakpoint
or echo of ecv
um we we decided that this uh breakpoint
or ecv will be deletion zero and one
deletion below or one deletion above
this mic value will be considered as
intermediate so this will be in the
category in damaged
then if the mic we obtained was a
more than one deletion above this uh
break points or a curve uh
uh or let's see two or three deletion
Above This will be in the resistant
category and if it's four or more than
four it will be in the highly resistant
category and the same for the mic below
um the the breakpoint or the ickov ecv
okay then it will be a sensitive
category or the highly sensitive
category
and if sometimes we have two breakpoints
teaching this means that you know that
uh we have a breakpoint below which The
Strain is considered as susceptible or
above which uh the second break point
above which the The Strain is considered
as resistant so in this case what we
take is that we take one deletion below
the susceptible breakpoint and one
dimension above the resistance
breakpoint to define the intermediate
category
okay so now if we have one mic with one
um with one uh techniques uh which is in
the intermediate for example category
and in the resistant one for the second
test
it we consider that as a Minor error if
we have more than two categories uh
difference we have a major error and if
we have more than three categories
difference we consider that as a very
major error
and with that
um
so here is the table I'll show you
before and remember that there is a lot
of blank cells so with that we could
compare only
22 of our observation uh based on break
point
49.6 based on ikov ecv and more than 50
percent of our observation could not be
compared due to lack of criteria at
least in one of the two consortia if not
in both
okay
so we could only uh
um then we could only
um compare data for uh let's say
two-thirds of
what we we have as as uh Records
so then we did some contingency tables
to compare the Micronaut mic and the
es11
which were categorized okay and you see
that we have
um on the on the on the right of this
contingency table you see it's within
accuracy and you see that only 52
percent
uh we have only 52 percent of accuracy
between the two methods which is really
low
and but we have a few major error only
two but a lot of uh
sorry we had only two very major error
and the majority of difference was due
to minor or major error and this is for
a breakpoint as you can see on the top
um on the top of the slide and on the
bottom of the slide it's the same thing
but with uh ecv ekov as
um as criteria then you see that the
accuracy is also very low around 55
percent
so at that time we wonder if our
approach was valid and was able to see
the similarity between
so what we did is that we then compared
the mic we obtained with the Micronaut
um
visual reading or the mic which is here
indicated by m and V and with the micro
not read with the spectrophotometer
which is indicated here by MN and you
see that in this case there is very few
uh major error and very major error and
that accuracy in this case is of uh 90
percent
and uh which is data obtained with
breakpoint as criteria and on the bottom
you see the same with ecv echoff uh as
criteria and it's the same we have an
accuracy around uh 90 and almost no very
major error and very few major and minor
error so meaning that our approach was
valid but this approach showed that
whatever we can do the the comparison
based on mic and comparison of mic
either rho mic or categorization of mic
was not a good way to to compare the two
the two methods
so yeah this was our first conclusions a
huge effort is still needed to complete
interpretation criteria in both
consortia remember all these black cells
in our table and as I said that the
comparison of clsi this is two caste
growth micro dilution susceptibility
testing is absolutely not trivial and
cannot be done by direct mic comparison
neither by categorization
so this leads us to take another
approach uh to be able to compare the
results we obtained by clsi or recas
protocol let's say by
um is yeast one sensitizer or
micronutaya
so for that
um we decided to use the information we
had on the resistance genes
let's say all the genes I presented you
before
and to do so
uh we decided to evaluate the
concordance between this one sensitite
and Micronaut am using 50 strains which
were genetically characterized for the
the antifungal resistant genes so 22
candidate begins 18 candida gabrata five
candida lucitani and five candida hours
today I present you the data only for
candidal beacons and candida vibrato
so strains were sampled before and after
several days of treatments and or
isolated in a breakthrough episodes
and we determine the point mutation
responsible for resistance uh
in the resistance
genes of the resistance strains as
compared to the isogenic receptive
restraints sampled at the beginning of
the treatment in a single patient
and we thus observed it if a mic
elevation could be measured for the
corresponding drugs with both Metals in
the strain containing uh in the
resistance strain containing mutations
okay so I'll just remind you uh so first
we will look at the Azure data and I
just remind you how what the gene
involved in the resistance so here it's
the Azure susceptible yeast so the
others enter it's a cell bind to the ERG
11
enzyme and the organism enzyme once
blocked uh could no more lead to
biosynthesis of ergosterol but instead
to this 14 Alpha metal 3 6 diode which
is a toxic compound
so it what we can have I remind you is
that we can have a mutation in the
target at 11 so early 11 is one of the
resistance sheet we can have mutation in
upc2 controlling the expression of 11.
we can also have mutation in um
Tech 1 or ma1 which are regulating the
expression of the virtual the
transporter sheet but yeah and
but we can also have mutation in other
um in other genes involved in the sterol
biosynthesis this is important because
in this case for example if F3 is
mutated you have no more synthesis of
this toxic compound and the strain can
still grow
and for some strains we have uh some uh
you will see that you you will see that
several strains show very high mics and
it's because they
um
have
um acquisition of several mutations in
several resistance genes
okay so here the data we obtained so
let's let me explain you this table
so in a in a single Square you see that
you have three different strain let's
say here dsy 2321 in black and two red
strain the sy2322 and this one 23 and
53. so the gs1 23 29 21 in Black was the
susceptible strain which was recovered
from patient one uh before the beginning
of the treatment
and the following strain were sampled
after
several week of treatment so first the
23 22 and then the 2323 and you see that
in the susceptible strain the black one
there is no mutation uh neither in
tacuan or upc2 but you see here this
little star this means that we had a
mutation but in only one copy of the
early 11 Gene I just remind you that
candidal beacons is a diploid and that
we need to have a mutation in both copy
of the genes to see
um to have expression of the mutation
you see that in the first uh red strain
22 22 we have mutation in the taquan
Gene and in the early 11 Gene this time
the mutation is almost zygot meaning
it's present in both copy of uh those
genes
and you see that
that let's strain on the top we have
mutation in upc2
now if we look at the mic you see that
we indicated to mic for the different
drugs
for the susceptible strain and we
indicate it by plus five for example and
the color
this means that the mic of the first red
strain 2322 is uh at five deletion uh
more than the receptible strain okay and
on for each drug you see on the left y o
meaning yeast one this is the data we
obtained with this one and on the right
you see M and V this is the data we
obtaining for Micronaut and both read by
visually
and you see for all the strains that as
soon as you have mutation you have an
increase in the mic both for each one
and for mnv and when we look at the mean
mic increase for each drug you see that
there is no major difference between uh
yeast one or mnv if you look at the
bottom of each table you can see mean
mic increase and if you compare the two
columns for each stroke you don't see a
major difference between them
and so we did that for candida IB
constraints and on the B table we did
that also for a Candida grabrata a
couple of strains
so then we did the same with the
candidates so I just remind you that the
resistance to candines was due to a
mutation in the target of the candidates
encoded by Gene fks1 but also if Case
two for candida grabrata only and on the
bottom you can see that there is two hot
spots where the mutation responsible for
resistance are located and on color I
indicated the position uh well the amino
acid involved in this resistance
and
we identified that you see here on this
table that some mutation in FKS one or
FKS one two four candida Cooperative
represent when there is a cross
so you see that for candidate beacons we
have only one uh couple of isogenic
strains and then we have let's say
single strands this means that we don't
have the isogenic one uh as these
strains were isolating during a
breakthrough episode and we don't have
the the
susceptible strain before beginning of
the treatment
okay so here we just put an r as the the
mic were really high for both this one
and back or not and here again it's the
same principle uh you you have the mic
for the C70 percent and then you have
the elevation of mic for the The Strain
bearing mutation and you see again when
you look at the Mi mean MIT increase at
the bottom of the table that the
increase of mic in the resistance strain
for both uh system are comparable
foreign
so then uh our last question was uh
does it exist a difference between the
micronautium red visually or
um uh by the spectrophotometer and
interpreted with the software
so here is the result it's exactly the
same as we did before comparing the
rolly the the mic so you have for
candidal begins and candida garabrata as
also echinocanine's mics and you see
that we consider that no
difference in the mic between the two
way to read the Micronaut or one
dilution it's comparable and you can see
that more than 97
of the mic were similar uh if they're
the the plate were read visually or
spectrophotometrically
and it's true for candidal beacons with
adults and canines and for gabrata it's
a bit lower but still very good we have
95 percent of the mic which are
identical uh between visual or
spectrophotometrical reading of the
blade and 92.2 percent for candidates so
there is and when there is difference
there is no change in the interpretation
uh
for for this mic
uh here is the same but here it's
presented uh not by strange but by drug
and you see that we have 90 percent of
the observation that is uh the same uh
all all um uh strains we read
confunded ninety percent of the mic were
identical if it's read visually or
spectrometrically spectro
photometrically so to conclude
photometric reading is reliable and easy
to use and this will simplify the
laboratory workflow as
the system is connectable to our list
this will avoid transcription errors
so the last things we evaluate is the
reproducibility of the Micronaut am
versus this one since the title
so what we did is that we repeated uh 10
times the reading of
atccc 6253 which is a Candida crazy ice
strain the same for the atcc candida
perhapsilosis and also for the sc-53 14
strain of candida Advocates and with
this we determined a model mic
using the sensitizer here indicated by y
o modal mic okay and we calculated how
much observation
fold in this model mic range or is it
equal to the model mic and you see that
for the yeast one it the results are
pretty good and I indicated in yellow
um the observation for which the percent
uh
of the observation in the model range is
below 90 percent and you see that we
have five
yellow cells
we did the same for a Micronaut here in
red read visually and also the same for
the micro node red with the
spectrophotometer here in yellow and you
see that in this case all the
observation uh we have uh four in more
than 90 percent in the model uh range of
correspond to the modal mic we have only
one
um one observation here for any de la
foreign
you see that two of the observation for
this group were not equal to the model
mic
so it seems that the Micronaut has a
slight better uh reproductibility and
repeatability
as compared to the to the yeast one
sensitizer
so to conclude this 2D
we observed that comparison of clsi
versus u-cast growth micro deletions
susceptibility test is absolutely not
trivial and cannot be done by direct mic
comparison neither by categorization
that the use of genetically
characterized trains for antifungal drug
resistance is a very good solution to
evaluate new antifungal susceptibility
testing method
and in this study we clearly show that
this one interpreted with CLS architaria
and Micronaut am interpreted with yukash
criteria are equivalent and able to
detect elevation of mic due to point
mutations in antifungal resistance genes
we observe that the repeatability
reproducibility was slightly better with
the macronutrium and we also clearly
defined that the visual and photometric
reading of the micronutrium are
equivalent and that the photometric
reading can simplify and even improve
the laboratory with workflow due to the
possibility to be connected to the list
and so after that we decided to um
Implement in routine the microlent am in
our Laboratory
with that I'd like to thanks all the
people involved in this study so my boss
Professor silver curb the mycology team
of of our Institute the professor
Dominic Sandra who retired last November
the doctor Frederick Lamont
with who I'm working in close contact
every day the people of the Diagnostic
lab the head of the lab Dr kiprodon and
also the technician involved in this
Duty
in addition to Nathan I'd like to thank
the bioinformaticians who helped us to
analyze all the Dhaka Dr harshoti I'd
like to thank Nicola who did a wonderful
job doing all these experiments in only
uh two months and a half and to conclude
I'd like to thanks Robert and Tilly from
Berlin who were really fine with me
helping me a lot and with who I had a
very uh fruitful conversation
and with this I thank you for your
attention and I'm now ready for taking
questions thank you
thank you Alex for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
okay Alex we already have some great
questions coming in so I'm just going to
dive in here
starting with question one how do you
rate the differences between youcast and
clsi methodology and breakpoints
well
the difference is is really it doesn't
seems it's major but it's really you can
we observe that with the difference of
mic we measure that we I cannot say
there is one one method which is more
more
valuable than another one it depends
where you live and what you want but
um and clearly that we need an effort to
to to harmonize the two
thank you our next question do you see a
need for harmonization
just a minute someone's writing that we
don't hear q a
but it's possible
let's see uh
I'm hearing it coming through on my end
um
let me make a note to this person but
let's continue with the Q a
um okay
uh it's question two do you see a need
for harmonization of methodologies and
interpretive standards
yeah it's it's in the same way as in the
same package as the first question I
would say uh clearly if we want to be
able to compare experiments done with
one or the other methodology we need to
have more harmonization and we also need
to feel all these white cells in my
table uh to be able to interpret uh data
and
um there was already one essay of
harmonization which was really helpful
but we still need effort
thank you Alex our next question
how do you rate the usability of
Micronaut am in the routine lab workflow
um
it's it's really it's really easy to use
I mean the the two the two methods are
are comparable uh they are as easy both
of them are are really easy uh and the
what we experience in our lab is that we
connected we read Micronaut am with the
spectrophotometer and we send the data
directly in the Lis so this was for us
the the the
very huge Improvement as comparison what
we did before uh because then we don't
have to reconscribe the the results and
that's very helpful
but the the macronaut is really easy to
use
excellent
now Alex based on your study results
which method standard do you recommend
to other Laboratories
well
um
it depends where you live I would say
because if you live in Europe the the
breakpoints and all the the criteria
given by ucas are based on European
epidemiology so it's more reflecting
what we will encounter in our labs in
Europe
in contrast if you are in U.S I would
use clsi because the scls Secretariat
are based on the on the the American
epidemiology so there is not one which
is better than the other one it's just
depending where you live and and what
you will encounter in your lab and in
our lab it's why we wanted to to use
Micronaut because it's based on on the
ucas criteria and it's what we need in a
European lab
thank you and I think we can squeeze
another question here and this question
is two parts
were the two fungal athletes easy to use
and did you find them relatively user
friendly
well they are easy to use
uh uh for my point of view
uh I I won't say it's as user friendly
as doing uh
um as I can say
um mic with a strip or a Kirby Bauer
essay which is just
smaller
I don't know if the word in English now
but if you want to test several
several drugs at the same time it's the
best way and it's much easier to do a
micronutrium or Yeast ones acid tighter
than doing the classical clsi or uks
protocol I can say because then it will
take a very long time and with the the
Micronaut am it will take let's say five
minutes so yeah it's it's much longer
than just doing strips but it's much
quicker than doing a full ucas protocol
thank you Alex and do you have any final
comments for our audience
yeah I I
I propose people to just to try and um
if they have a doubt that it's it's
really
um it's really easy to use and I guess
that using ucast in routine request
using Micronaut am in routine will will
be more
um helpful for our clinician as in
Europe we are facing uh um
European streets and
[Music]
um
also I would suggest that
to use the the reader uh it will give a
much easier flow in the lab and but
sometimes to have a high control
especially when you use
um fungistatic drug like adults and uh
and candidal beacons for example we know
that we have a trading effect
what I can say that when we use the
Micronaut am we always control this
trailing effect and as you could observe
in the data I presented you the visual
reading and the spectrophotometer
reading were really comparable meaning
that the software is able really to to
detect this trading we also added
Micronaut proposed to add um
a compound which will limit the trading
of the strains probably it's why we
didn't observe so so many difference
between reading by eye or reading with
respect of photometer
but I will suggest to have
um an eye control just to be sure that
what the spectrophotometer give and the
soft give is is the truth and um yeah
just to have a kind of a quality control
sometimes but from our experience we
never encounter a major difference
forever
thank you so much
and I again I would like to thank Dr
Alex cost for her time today and for her
important research now if you do have
additional questions for Dr cost you can
find her email in the biography section
of our virtual Studio here but you can
also submit them during that on-demand
session um during our on-demand session
but I do want to thank lab Roots also
and our sponsor broker microbiology and
diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and again
any questions that we did not have time
for today or those submitted during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration today's webcast can be
viewed on demand and Labyrinth will
alert you via via email shortly when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
that's all for now we thank you again
for joining us take care everyone
bye-bye